hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast proposed rule for the Medicare
clinical diagnostic laboratory test
payment system I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth for more
information please visit lab roots com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in a
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Jerry stringham
president of medical technology partners
he has worked as a reimbursement
strategy consultant since the 1980s when
we began providing reimbursement
consulting to diverse device diagnostic
and pharmaceutical companies Jerry holds
a BS in mechanical engineering from the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and an MBA from Harvard Business School
he has been part of five medical device
startup organizations operating out of
New England and has grown m tpem tepees
client list over 150 clients Jerry
founded medical technology partners in
1998 to fill the growing need for
business oriented reimbursement
consulting his experience in industry
including as a principal in the health
economics practice of a major CRO brings
expertise to new technology
reimbursement challenges I will now turn
it over to Jerry for his presentation
hello everybody thank you for joining me
today and hearing about the perspectives
on changing reimbursement in the
laboratory system I've been part of the
healthcare reimbursement system since
the 1980s and right now we're facing one
of the seminal moments for payment for
laboratory developed tests if you're a
company who makes hospital inpatient
products 1983 was the change when drgs
came into play in 1998 the hospital
outpatient system went from being a cost
based system to a prospective payment
system in 1993 physician services went
from being usual and customary charges
to a system based on relative value
units or right now this law this change
is the beginning of a massive change in
the way that diagnostic tests are going
to be paid for and you have an
opportunity to participate in it and you
certainly would want to know how your
tests or how your companies would be
taken effect so that's what we're here
about is to share of this information so
what is the presentation about it's
about the proposed rule for the Medicare
clinical diagnostic laboratory test
payment system this was published in the
Federal Register on october first of
this year so this is hot off the press
was first previewed by health department
of health and human services on sep
tember 25th they're asking for public
comment so comments to the proposed rule
this is your big opportunity to make a
statement is due by November 24th of
2015 if you want to know what this rule
is and read it yourself it's the address
the URL is right there on the slide and
I certainly encourage you to do so so
what is our objective our objective is
to alert you to some upcoming proposed
changes in how Medicare will pay for
clinical diagnostic laboratory tests
let's see DLT alert participants to key
reimbursement proposals that could
affect laboratory developed test that's
the ldt so that's different and make
sure that participants know how to
access access the sort source document
that's on the previous page and alert
participants to Medicare's potentially
changing congressional intent to the law
that was passed last year that laid the
groundwork for this and you know I think
some of the proposed changes you know
are harmful to companies and they need
to be involved what is important about
laboratory developed tests laboratory
developed tests are one of the
foundations of personalized medicine so
personalized medicine is kind of a buzz
word it's also called precision medicine
in some fields it's another permutation
of the same thing i but the whole idea
of health care under personalized
medicine is to deliver the right care to
the right patient at the right time
personalized to their own individual
genome structure disease and so on and
LD tease now have been put under FDA
enforcement discretion but the FDA has
promised change the enforcement
discretion means that there is no 510 K
or de novo or PM a require required so l
DTS have been
had a license to go to market without
notifying and have a no formal
application of the FDA LD teas are by
definition or invented developed and run
in the same single location in a lab
that is clia-certified LD TS often have
multiple inputs like biomarkers and
other data and often an algorithm that
are combined to provide some useful
diagnostic information to a patient or
to their professional so what is the
historical context for Medicare's
proposed rule published on October first
what brought this about well on April
April first of 2014 the protecting
access to Medicare act of 2014 known as
pama was enacted into law section 216 of
Pama which is entitled improving
medicare policies for clinical
diagnostic laboratory tests begins to
change the medicare payment system for
clinical lab diagnostic tests by
establishing a market-based payment
system for the clinical lab fee schedule
CFS this law covered much more than just
the the laboratory developed tests at
the time it passed it made a lot of
turned a lot of heads for other reasons
the healthcare reimbursement system was
moving from a coding system called icd-9
to icd-10 that law changed changed the
implementation date from 2014 2 2015
much to the shock of many people it
provided a fix to on a temporary basis
to physician fee payments
and it also you know part of this
provision was called for a change in the
medical Medicare regulatory body body
something that's kind of referred to as
diagnostic max not to implement policy
coverage that particular provision that
has not been addressed or it looks like
it won't be addressed by CMS but you
know most significantly here for this
talk the section 216 talks about a
market-based payment system that changes
the way that CMS determines payment
traditionally the payments have been
okay the traditionally the payments have
been made on me on a fee schedule basis
and that had been determined by a
variety of methods and the paradigm
shift now is causing for the methods to
go to go towards more market-based
economics thank you what is important
about the clinical length of fee
schedule payment system Medicare is a
system isn't is insurance that covers
people 65 years and older and and some
disabled people a lot of people a lot of
tests it's a big part of your business
Medicare establishes payment via the
schedule and Medicare also is the key
influencers and how commercial insurers
viewing diagnostic technology that are
basically the opinion leader so when
Medicare is put it through this change
even though Medicare itself is
approximately 50 million patients the
more than 100 million commercial
insurers and 68 million under the
Medicaid program are also significantly
impacted so Medicare controls the coding
coverage and payment amounts for the
coding for all systems and coverage and
payment for Medicare recipients they
implement coverage and payment amounts
through either national coverage
determinations for example company
called exact sciences developed a test
called Cola guard and if there is no NCD
then coverage is made through the local
coverage determinations and they're
handled by the 12 there's 12
jurisdictions of Medicare administrative
contractors currently run by eight
different companies across the United
States so each have jurisdiction in
their area for example Palmetto is 11
Medicare administrative contractor or
Mac they can trouble they control a
policy for the virginias north west
virginia and virginia and the carolinas
south and north carolina so they cover
those four states for example our test
semantics confusing you may want to know
pamela defined advanced diagnostic
laboratory tests and gave it
preferential reimbursement status so you
know you listen to that preferential
reimbursement status so they've created
a category of tests that they want to
help they are not looking to cut off at
the knees that's what Congress did and
many of the laboratory tests could fall
under this definition of an ad LT the ad
LT definition became part of pima while
many national organizations were arguing
with the FDA about what should be
regulated and whether the FDA was going
to
issue its enforcement discretion this is
not the same or has really anything to
do with what was going on with the FDA
these are parallel programs that can act
independently of other one really is
about a payment system and one is about
the regulatory approval and in fact you
know as this law was being passed the
people involved with writing a law were
aware of the the issues around the FDA
and deliberately wrote it in a way that
would allow it to be implemented
separately pama defines new FDA cleared
or approved tests as ad LTS however you
do not have to be FDA cleared or
approved to be a Navy Lt it's just said
it it automatically can face that
preferred reimbursement status the
association of molecular pathology a
large largest group of professional
associations of pathologists in the
country has argued that ldt should be
called laboratory developed procedures
instead of laboratory developed tests
other national organizations also like
the term molecular tests which is often
a term used for genetic or genomic tests
that use DNA and RNA biomarkers but one
Mac palmetto defined a different term
for a molecular diagnostic test and
palmetto which is the mac and has been
the most active in defining
reimbursement policy in the country
among the Medicare contractors to find
an MDT as any test that involves the
detection or identification of new
I acids like DNA and RNA proteins
chromosomes enzymes cancer chemotherapy
sensitivity or any any other metabolites
the test may or may not include multiple
components an MDT may consist of a
single mutation analysis identification
or may or may not rely upon an algorithm
or other form of data evaluation and
derivation so it's very comprehensive
and it also I think it speaks to the the
powerful tools that are available to
help identify a patient's condition and
prognosis so this is this is the
broadest definition out there really for
diagnostic testing so let's take a break
I've been thrown a whole lot of acronyms
at you so see if you remember you know
which which codes represent which so
cvlt adlt ldt LTP and MDT so here we go
there they all are clinical diagnostic
lab tests advanced diagnostic lab tests
laboratory developed test laboratory
developed procedures and molecular
diagnostic tests on the same family but
they mean different things and which one
you are you know may may make a
semantical difference of which one you
are may make a difference and a reason
to comment on this rule or at least
understand the rule is see end up in the
in the in the playing field that you
want to be in when it comes to
reimbursement so what does the rule do
it's moving to market based payment all
clinical lab tests can be called CD LTS
but payment has historically been
figured out and justed administrative ly
by CMS tests are described with a code
and
you may have heard of a CPT code which
is a coding system controlled by the
American Medical Association or CMS as a
system called hick pics and the values
for each of these independent diagnostic
tests and they are put into the clinical
lab fee schedule and published in the
proposed rule of an annual rule by CMS
often the initial and changed pricing
has been very unpopular with the labs
running the test as has been the
methodology and Congress in the in the
pama rule bypassed the CMS historical
approach reporting labs though under
this process will be required to tell
CMS who tests were sold to both in terms
of test volume and price so it is
required of manufacturers of tests to
tell CMS how much they got paid for
their tests its market-based pricing
system tests sold in year one will be
reported to CMS during the first quarter
of next year at least that's the plan so
in 2016 by the end of the first quarter
we will begin to see what data is
available on CMS will use 2016 data to
establish 2018 payment so CMS will use a
weighted meeting median from all the
reporting labs will be calculated and
CMS we use that price for the test in
all of calendar year 2018 so it's
calendar year 3 so essentially they
collect data in one year the next year
they evaluate the data and they
corporated into future years fee
schedules
so adlt fork in the road most see blts
can be sold by a number of labs and any
number of companies can develop tests
for Medicare and the clinical lab fee
schedule establishes payment Pam in the
proposed rule published is a reporting
nightmare for labs with lots of well or
recognized test run by themselves
competitors and also being paid by
commercial insurers as well as Medicare
ad LTS will be different because they
will be unique from the one individual
lab that developed a test and the term
adlt avoids the confusing semantics of
some of the other acronyms of alphabet
soup that that proposed before when ad
lt's were called LD tease the labs were
often so unique and so new that they
would not qualify for national coverage
to decision just determination so each
of the individual max would set up their
own local coverage determinations for
the lab in their jurisdiction and set
the coverage and payment rules based on
that ad LT is in the preferential
reimbursement Congress seems to have
recognized that these ad lt's are going
to be key to personalized medicine what
is it about personalized medicine that
has people excited the idea of giving a
drug only to somebody that benefits is
one of them and you know targeting the
right therapy for the right person so
there's there's initiative zero all the
way up to the White House to encourage
precision and personalized medicine so
the law defines three ways the test
could possibly become an ad LT Congress
didn't want innovative technologies to
be bogged down when the old approach is
which has huge delays in coverage and
huge delays in establishing fair
reimbursement if a test is recognized as
an ad LT Congress wanted a way for them
come up with a unique code that didn't
rely on the AMA cpt process which can
take 18 months or more or other CMS
coding approaches the unique test the ad
LT is market introduction could be done
at the company's own list price so if
you have a new ad LT you set the price
not not cross walking and not some of
these other techniques that CMS is used
to establish payments several months
later after you provide a reports actual
commercial sales an actual price the
weighted median calculation for that
specific test is used and if too low
compared to the original list price the
lab service provider may ocms money I
think the the cutoff is somewhere around
thirty percent so you know if you list
the price of two thousand and thirty
percent below that below 1400 you'd
expect to provide a rebate he sets the
way the way the law appears to be
implemented so what is the reaction to
the proposed rule because you know we've
been waiting since since Pam was first
introduced for CMS to read the rule and
begin writing regulations around the
rule well we could tell that CMS was
changing things the original rule talked
about DNA RNA or proteins as being
components of the test of an ad LT well
CMS said we don't really need proteins
so that just a DNA and RNA they added a
distinction saying that the test had to
demonstrate clinical uniqueness and
you know our impression is that clinical
uniqueness is a bit of a slippery slope
is it requires some interpretation and
in in the hospital outpatient system
when a new device is introduced it's
eligible for a pass-through payment for
a couple of years CMS introduce the
concepts the new device must show a
substantial clinical improvement over
something else that was already
available or what it what it might
replace and they've used very strict
interpretation of what that is and not
provided the pass-through for devices
and the concern might be here that
worthy tests that meet the definition
has intended by Congress for an ad LT
will not meet it here so and then
finally a very restrictive process
defining algorithm was proposed which
would you know further limit adlt
definitions CMS held a public meeting on
October 18th with which myself and some
of my colleagues were able to attend and
you know CMS asserted that the agencies
changed laws passed by Congress all the
time and that the CMS legal team said
that the changes you know were only done
because they were legally permitted
given the definition that was in the law
that we can't just do everything
ourselves but you know to remove the
word protein I really couldn't see any
justification for doing that I mean I a
protein a test comprising a protein
analysis is equally as potentially
life-saving tool patient who's going to
undergo chemotherapy from from a drug
with tremendous side effects is one that
analyzes RNA or DNA potentially
so what can you do you know you're in
the right place right now you're you
know getting a presentation about this
it's a you know huge opportunity to
create a plane playing field for your
company where the reimbursement rules
are better than they've been the max
potentially won't be able to be up on
price the way they have for a lot of
products that have come out using code
stacking or gap filling pricing methods
which in some cases has brought the
price from a laboratory test down by
more than eighty percent from where the
developer wanted the test to be priced
you know normally normally when you're
developing a reimbursement strategy or
reimbursement driven commercialization
strategy for a product you have the
rules already kind of laid out it's it's
like being given a hand to play in a
game of cards and you're playing bridge
and you have to play the cards to win
the game of bridge in this case you're
being handed cards and right now with
this rule still being open you have a
chance to redefine what that game is you
might have a hand that's much better for
pinochle so the the the time to look at
this if you're in the space is is right
now what would a strategy be and you're
the the process that we go through
something called an environmental scan
the environmental scan now has been
handed to us via this federal
registration publication you can read it
the links in the beginning that's 30 37
page triple column densely word
government publication
and you can get through it and begin to
understand it or you can ask for help
too we will be happy to help and you
know I guess the question I would have
is do you want to be part of the process
and comment on these proposed rules
which would be due no later than
November 24th an innovative lab service
provider developing or currently
marketing an LD t you know maybe left
out and not be eligible for an ad LT
that's one of the one of the concerns if
you choose not to comment you know
another foundation of strategy is to
narrow scenario planning what if some of
the current proposals remain the same in
some change but definitions change could
timing shorten or lengthen two years of
having free rein over pricing versus
three years should the product
development and marketing consider ideal
outcomes and also problematic ones what
does it mean for your products and you
know how much senior management time
should be diverted addressing these
upcoming changes and could outside
experts help those are questions for you
you know you know fortunate enough to
now provide a reimbursement support to
over 150 companies along with my
colleagues and I can tell you that
reimbursement is unique for each lab the
ideal reimbursement strategies is based
on the details of how reimbursement
works for that disease for that test for
that benefit category for that type of
ensure for that jurisdiction it's
different for military patients than for
for those with Blue Cross Blue Shield
and different tests appeal to different
market segments
so you know what we what we do is is
sweat the details try to figure out what
it takes for a valuable test to reach
patient patient that needs it can
benefit from the information we can't
cover everything that might be relevant
to your company's own situation you know
during during this call but you know
hopefully the things I've reviewed here
provided you know some background on why
what this law is what Pam is and why it
may be very important for your company
the reimbursement is always driven by
your particulars and not broad
generalities but the broad generalities
define the playing field that you have
to operate under and right now it's in a
state of flux and there are unintended
consequences of some of the things that
are in there that can be adjusted you
have an opportunity to do that this this
brief introduction is just you know part
of the process of how you assess plan
and act you know could certainly wish
you great luck with anything that you
need to do here so I thank you for your
time and attention and anything that you
need to do or if you want help you know
I hope you'll feel free to you know send
me an email or my email address is there
and I you know I'm available now to
answer any questions you may have thank
you thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can't submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can
and our first question is is there an
important bottom line to these proposed
Medicare rules and if so what is it I do
see a written question here is there a
portent bottom line to these proposed
Medicare rules and if there is what is
it that's a really good question
Medicare is gradually shifting the
clinical lab fee schedule to one based
on actual commercial test sales that's
kind of the bottom line it's a
market-based calculation rather than one
that may use traditional CMS approaches
like gap filling or cross walking to an
existing code many many current
providers don't like the current system
because they end up having their tests
under appreciated when the CL FS comes
out for their particular test so so this
this new system the bottom line is we're
going from a process driven system to
define payment to one that's based on
market realities thank you
what tests do alts include and what is
the difference compared with Md tease
um we may be having a little sound
difficulty so i will i will repeat that
one what tests do alts include and what
is its difference compared with md TS
thank you i heard that perfectly this
time an ad LT is defined by pama and the
rule that just came out it is it it is
the advanced diagnostic laboratory test
is an indication that you meet the
criteria for preferential payments for
several year period of time and can
access the market-based reimbursement
system that will be in the future so
that's that's a new definition and
molecular diagnostic test could be an ad
LT or it may not be an ad LT you know
one is kind of based on on science you
know what does the test comprise an ad
LT provides information that indicates
that it's eligible for certain payment
category so you know I hope that that
answers your question there
your next question is how will CMS to
find the scope of the market in quotes
for the reporting requirement and to
calculate market-based pricing
well first of all I think we can
influence that by based on what is what
the comments are that that they receive
what what we do know about it so far is
the calculation method that they propose
so which is to use the mean pricing
based on the information they receive to
establish the reimbursement level and
see if I caught the whole question there
and you know as far as the particulars
for an individual circumstance you know
may be different if there's more than
one lab and so on so and you know how
they how they average that but you know
generally they'll take all the tests and
calculate a median level and that's the
base that they'll use but the
information they collect in 2016 would
be analyzed and part of the rulemaking
process in 2017 and then incorporated
into the fee schedule in 2018 you know
I'd like to point out that that that
process of using economic information
collected in one year analyzed in the
second year and incorporated into the
fee schedule in the third year is the
same basic philosophy that they used for
hospital inpatient payment and for
hospital outpatient payment right now
they there's it's a little trickier
because they calculate costs indirectly
by using charges and then reducing it
through a formula that they derive but
it's the basic concept is the same how
much did it cost based on the there
best methodology available and they're
saying their best methodology of
determining the market is to have
manufacturers tell metell of these
diagnostic tests tell them how much
they're getting paid and using that
information if there are no more
questions I would like to once again
thank Jerry stirring them for his
presentation do you have any final
comments jury
I just like to repeat this is a seminal
moment for her laps and in the way that
reimbursement is set if your hospital
inpatient you administrator you remember
when drgs came into play if you deal
with the hospital outpatient you
remember when a PCS started and in the
lab lab schedule and lab introduction
process what an ad LT is you'll remember
2015 and and the implementation of that
in 2016 I think it's a good thing to
understand what is happening and where
it's going to go and how it affects your
company is very complicated and it's
it's worth trying to understand it and
what the key attributes are going to be
for you to be a success in this new
market driven pricing world so
understanding what your your clinical
more than what your clinical validity
and utility is and how to / / overcome
reimbursement barriers and still the
coverage barriers that come with a
system so you know I thank you for the
opportunity to tell you a little bit
about this I think so it's an exciting
but a bit frightening time so but mostly
it's good news i think so i encourage
you to get involved and take advantage
of it to help your tests you know help
the patients that were designed to help
so thank you for for your attention and
you know feel free to look us up we can
be of any help Thanks thank you today's
webcast will be available on demand for
I'm sorry today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May eleventh 2016
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
see you next time goodbye